[Music]
hello how are you healthy to go out jaramillo
with your brief informative today
wednesday december 2 the council of
the city of las vegas discussed options
to honor the former boss of sapo
lección and 6 a petition to rename
a street in downtown  of the city has
generated 25,000 signatures but this morning
the mayor who spread the germ took
the issue up in town hall to
discuss options she had previously
said her tribute needs to be something more
original than a street name
clark county is accepting
applications for  Its
Small Business Grant Program
Local business owners could
receive up to $30,000 depending
on the number of employees.
Recipients of these funds are also being allowed
to reapply
but first-time businesses are given priority.
The
deadline to apply is this coming
December 22. The links to apply for
this aid are  on our website
klinsmann dotcom
and the window to sign up for
health insurance through
nevadas the link is already available this
year there are 50 plans you can
choose from officers ask the public to ensure that they
process their registration
through a professional  and graduate the
deadline to buy register is January 15
of this coming year now
we pass with the weather
forecast a partially sunny day is expected with
a little breeze today's maximum
will be in the 60s and the minimum 36 degrees
that it has  One good day I am Sal and
Jaramillo and this was and Disney in Spanish
[Music]